on a clear day up on the moors you can  just see Tenma and all the villages and  towns that surround the area just  everything is so open and beautiful  one of the great things about this part  of the world you've got everything  accessible from your doorstep  what I love about team bridge is its  range of market and coastal towns and  they all offer something different  there's lots of local produce and the  community is really independent and  those two things just work really well  together  there's loads of really unique  businesses here and it's so exciting to  see them doing their own thing there's  really positive culture among the people  here in team bridge  you